l a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuto in
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi siamo su su happy meal stato crei
domenica riesce iniziare così subito a
caso facciamo krhin crimson mansion
non so che cos'è ma non importa andiamo
a un livello a caso fu così che ci siamo
siamo con e baie di vai via la verità
che ti sei modificato ok ci siamo dove
cazzo stai mostrando ti sei verificatori
chi cazzo era quello no annunci sono già
bastardi che è stato e che oggi sono già
perché vabbè andiamo avanti non importa
john finta di niente non sto facendo la
casta attivando qualcosa ma non so
neanche che cosa
oddio cos'è aiuto aiuto mi stupro che
cos'è
le ha tirato la pedata in faccia
fantastico o c'è ragazzini che ci sia
perfetto allora andiamo avanti non so
bene che cazzo successo prima però sta
diventando manca breccia nella mappa la
mappa horror dianese cos'è sta scopo mio
zio residenti vi siano spesso ci metti
che succede ragazzi non sto facendo sta
facendo tutto lui
oh mio dio ma va bene dove il cazzo si è
finiti ragazzi cioè non è normale
cos'era ho vinto c'era questo alla fine
grande emersi ormai pietà omicidio e
omicidio allora cos'è hai il cuore
adatto per perdonarla ma non ce l'ho lo
ammazzo grazie mille abbiamo al cos'è
questo brutto pedofilo ragazzo di
livello sto facendo e lo slider
vabbè ammazziamo la grande quest'uomo h
gatto nel processo senza permesso dargli
una lezione cosa ha introdotto nel mio
accesso nel servizio permesso brutto
stronzo come ti permetti
ok ricordi questa vecchia donna che ha
mangiato tutti un biscotto ha mangiato
l'ultimo biscotto ma come ci per me
questa gente di vivere
oh mio dio questa questo è un cantante
gay
justin bieber
chi ha infettato la tua radio bene
andiamo a quest'ora libera capire se
l'unica è l'unico episodio di è più
visto nel quale sono partito con livelli
completamente nonsense
ma va bene così soul cake 6 spero sia
solo enigmista da perfetto siamo pari è
di oggi
raga questo e livello horror e la
puntata horror di happy with cioè per
caso stanno uscendo tutti gli horror
grandissimo ed il enigmista e giù il
enigmi alla fine ha fatto fuori non sa
che non lo sapeva nessuno e adesso si va
a ficcare nei cunicoli sotterranei anche
il papà di youtube sta esaltando il papà
di look e perché è morto va bene andiamo
a fare a fare altre vittime ragazzi e
fantastico no kat
ok non era esattamente cosa mi aspettavo
sono sicuro che è bene bene bene bene
bene c'è anche gli occhi fantastico
gioco la bellissima
questo mi è piaciuto un casino più che
altro per il finale va bene che faccio
uno slow motion così che abbiamo un po
che vi aspetto ci hanno ammazzato
entrambi nonno a edizione se ti ho
salvato la vita brutto stronzo un
vecchio mi devi la tua vita anche se
teheran i massi tipo 2 o 3 anni di vita
comunque me la devi extreme obstet
conran cosa devo fare
ok perfetto un livello meno uccelli
siamo anche il padre di uk dai ragazzi e
ce la facciamo mai o mio dio quebec
madonna mia che mamma mia ma si può e si
vede che il padre di yuki allenatissimo
simili che vai così senza braccia
machisti chi se ne fotte chiusa il
manubrio tanto vai
ok perfetto definita malissimo però che
ci posso fare
mamma mia grande luke finalmente fatto
un qualcosa nella tua vita ti sei reso
utile bastardo stronzo non devo invitare
tuo padre però uniti piacciono i miei
capezzoli vero guardali come mi sto
toccando a sexy sono molto sexy
siamo ragazzi stiamo cose no
hogan domandato gli ultimi oddio non mi
dire che vince lui sta benissimo
fantastico ok perfetto ragazzi si va
mangiamo avanti è se mamma mia che
chiede addominali che c'è al padre di uk
fermo fermo ferma che culo assurdo è sta
roba si muove per ora devo riuscire a
passare mai adesso no magari non ho
tempismo merda
devo andare a culo vai che culo no ferma
adesso mi ammazzo perché mi cappotto da
è attento e come faccio poi domandare
piano ovviamente domandare velocissimo
perché se non si spacca al vetro vai vai
vai così grande
abbiamo film no non è una merda perdono
lo sapevo state tranquilli lo sapevo
aiuti e che mi guardate ung la faccia lo
sapevo che era alla fine mi sono
preoccupato per niente per fare un po di
suspence figuratevi se non lo sapevo
allora diamanti escape the box e scappi
le box lo devo fare assolutamente eco
ninja maicon indiana jones falco si
spacca il vetro spa che ho detto senti
maledetto stronzo non sei più capace è
bravo di testa
un secondo di escape the box un record
incredibile che solo indiana può fare ok
raga schiavo che il padre di io canto
che figo addio ma è stata una figata
oddio chi è questo li porta con madoff
mamma mia che stuntman vajont fai vedere
chi sei dove andato a mio zio ha ucciso
da amadori fare assolutamente alla
nostra ficcata sorda vaio poi da chi sei
fai vedere lo stuntman che in te son
finita anche la madonna mia parate grava
ma è la figata assurda da questo è figo
vai così mamma mia senza luke chi se ne
fotte andiamo tema che per tutte se
lista c'è se lino che sta vincendo sono
topi sellino mi stavi sta abbattendo
capricci a vincere siamo madonna madonna
no che vivo e attivo certi come sta
andando avanti
cos'è sono con una gamba sola scatti
senza braccia senza mai così madonna
forse no senza testa buono funzione però
fatto canestro poi così madonna ancora
vivo come faccio a essere ancora vivo
mio dio
sono loro sono l'uomo bce
ho visto non si sa come ma ho vinto va
bene così va anche detto ball cos'è sta
roba in prima donna
sì sì l'ho presa con la bocca canestro
con la battaglia ho cambiato canestro
aspetta sarà impossibile far canestro
credo infatti sono già accaduto ma
affanculo tempo lombardo io ma devo
farlo col pad ma come cazzo si piglia
aspettate con le gambe collegando un pò
impossibile oddio accesso che ho fatto
che all'estero non ho vinto
è una cosa un po strano aspettate un
attimo finalmente bastarda reso tipi io
sono rimasto anche appeso non importa va
bene 39 per cento imposti gol mi mancava
dalla panchina berni allora dobbiamo
capirci un secondo
sì però devi concentrarti non fare
cazzone che se lo figlia nel capra anzi
ogni volta deve riuscirci
allora se risposta di quella [ __ ]
devo riuscirci non è possibile
no no no ogni donna raga forse mi è
venuto l'idea epica ma non so se
funzionano aspettate ok
[Musica]
le idee funzionano rops league però
ragazzi vuole ed i civilisti livelli mai
cose ci vuole un rock no fermi
ok mi chiamo già accadendo in partenza
vai e ti fai vedere chi sei
primo tentativo la prima volta nella
storia ok un braccio andato l'altro ti
serve quindi magari cerca di non fartelo
spezzare maledizione ma è così
spingi di addominali ma in sei bravo il
primo ok cazzo che il braccio mi serviva
però vai così no che culo assurdo che
culo astuto mi sono salvato la fine
mamma mia che addominali quest'uomo è
vai vai e di maio e di varianti varianti
dai ci sono ragazzi sono già l'ho preso
l'ho preso st votare impossibile st
parte non so come ho fatto a farla vai e
vai e ti fai vedere quanto manca la
prima prima che muoio se ok vai così
palla di cannone incredibile oh mio dio
bis dove sono devo farmi cadere tipo non
lo so se se devo farmi che ho vinto
grande ce l'ho fatta fare un rock swing
anche oggi fanta cos'è che manca andiamo
sullo sport o ragazzi stiamo aprendo
persona già stato prendiamo steve ok ci
siamo mai così non lo shock tutto il
primo tentativo di riuscirci il primo
come cazzo emesso babbo natale no fermi
nati allora indietro mamma mia che ninja
e ho beccato anche babbo natale già dove
ha fatto bene
lo sfogo challenge fa vj ragazzi ogni
livello lo avevo visto io a farlo con
silva è così poco challenge livello 1 è
una cosa un po strana perché non ho mai
fatti di poco challenge ma devo
riuscirci allora questa difficile questo
è di porca [ __ ] come faccia su per
questo punto dove ci sono passato a non
passare di sopra qua perché non voglio
passati sotto sono più figo e passoni
sopra o se è un po dj ho solo avuto
fortuna sono un po vj ha avuto fortuna
che dico raga mi manca un po troppo e
direi di fare slider boltro e il primo
livello dedicato ad lander che fa quale
typeface che figo che figata la devo
riuscire alla 5 palle subito merda è
impossibile racca perché sta roba va
anche oltre
ok corso beccato lo slider è riesplosa
la testa fanta te lo meritavi da un
secolo sta fine stronzo cosa ho fatto no
flashlight flashlight fantastico vai
così di testa al contrario no porca
[ __ ] 12 4 pagine le ho prese le altre
no però finito le palle [ __ ]
come si fa a fare il suo livello
maledetto grande una pagina l'ho presa e
rai che questo è molto più difficile che
abbia mai fatto forse c'è brutto stronzo
di merda va bene che è possibile [ __ ]
un'ora che ci sto provando ed è una roba
assurda sto boltro e tre pagine o mio
dio
forse ci dietro il cazzo devo riuscire a
beccare con una palla a due canestri
impossibile e vediamo che cazzo beh no
male
ok lo rifà che culo assurdo vediamo se
riesco a 34 pagine non sono riuscito a
vincere mi manca un home page ma
impossibile da prendere laga presto lo
chiudo qui perché non si può non
castelli dove piaciuto come al solito
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come ogni video
tratte nella descrizione sarà siete
coristi di scrivete che ci vediamo nel
prossimo vito bella ragazza
[Musica]